opération porte-à-porte pour la maire
sortante de saint cyr l'école qui a
lancé sa liste en décembre dernier avec
son équipe
saint cyr au coeur 2020 sonia brouch
rencontrent les habitants avec
l'objectif de les faire participer à la
construction de son programme
les points essentiels du prof du
programme vont être de remettre l'humain
au centre de saint siège on a on vienne
pas ses deux mandats à construire parce
que l'état comme vous le savez nous
demander de densifier nous sommes en
deuxième couronne il y a
bré difficultés pour se loger en région
parisienne cette fois ci bien maintenant
il va on va pouvoir se consacrer au
saint cyrien et aux services qu'on lui
propose dans son triptyque elle met un
point d'honneur à lutter contre
l'incivisme et les dégradations du
quotidien à valoriser le tissu
économique local ou encore revaloriser
le patrimoine sincères ayant l'idée
phare c'est vraiment de construire un
centre ville de redynamiser le commerce
est d'arriver à une vie de ville dans
laquelle on fait des choses ont fait pas
que venir dormir à partir travailler et
où on a envie d'aller au cinéma au
théâtre se promener un petit peu dans
nos parcs puisqu'on en a quand même de
très jolis pour saint cyr au coeur 2020
les opérations de tractage continue
jusqu'à la fin du mois et une réunion
publique se tiendra le 27 février
prochain
pour l'instant seulement deux listes se
sont déclarés dans la commune de saint
cyr l'école